the red thing you think about the my
hand is changing to confuse someone if I
do like this even do faster you probably
get confused and then stay by you hello
everyone I'm Zeke song I'm a
professional kung fu martial test I have
been training and teaching kung fu for
26 years today we're gonna look at a
movie Spirit and star fact to see how
realistic they are
that's very realistic stuff is the
fundamental training for any kind loan
weapon training including spear you have
to go through the staff training first
and then when you learn speed will
become much easier we do have a trading
issue called swap for example my staff
is here you're trying to grow my stuff
but I wear shove it you grab what you
grab empty and then I can use the back
to strike at you so that is a very
realistic as well
another real estate sweep staff is like
for the range for like say one two three
four many people here I can use the stop
okay like that that's a strip but once
down the street you can shoot you can
sweep like I mentioned before you
haven't used this energy to come back
you don't want to let the stuff drag you
away you'll use the energy and then come
back
that's very realistic as well the staff
guy he got a hit to hit flat far away in
kung fu we have another training it's
called the ground picnics you have no
how to fall someone trying to give you a
kick you jump in the air you land you
have to hold your Chi which is energy if
you don't hold your energy you land on
the ground you'll be like oh the energy
exclusive this you'll be like
not too painful all of the stuff
technique you can do it in real life
it's no problem nine give him nine
[Music]
that's a very good choreography very
Advanced spear is one of the challenging
weapons it's like a dragon dragon is
flexible soft and at the same time with
power as well if I'm holding a spear I'm
trying to strike to this way and then I
come back so I can bounce back so that's
where the flexibility is very important
so if the spear is not flexible will be
not that easy to bounce back
if you're very good with the Kung Fu you
can do like this no problem at all I'm
holding a spear this is called light
which is a block someone's trying to
stay by me you the sword I block I take
control and then I step
in the situation you don't know what's
going to happen if someone use a sewer
try to chop at your head the circle
still do the same but bigger the block
and take control and step you can move
around
for the martial art for Kung Fu you can
do that move even in a real situation
you can do the chalk like that that's no
problem
it's very common any kind of weapons you
break it it's a normally very common the
spear we use even the wooden wine they
made it by why the wax wood is very
flexible but like a plant you have the
water it will become dry out which means
there's no juice left inside it will be
very difficult to bounce you want to
bounce back so you have to do the
maintenance use too much power it will
just pop break approaching take a handy
drinking pain
this stuff is different from normal
stuff normal stuff it just depends on
your own height the stuff should be like
with your own height or five fingers
taller see this stuff is longer it's a
more challenge if I hold it like a
normal stuff I can strap the stuff
easily against track with the back but
the loom wiping is very difficult if you
strap back it's going to be challenged
long weapon is a big challenge you can
see the moves you have used a lot of
strip you can see he sweeps the legs
that's a very good choreography also the
style is very flexible he used the
flexibility to bounce back to hit
another opponent he does this the circle
like spear he combines some spear move
as well and it's like he combine
everything together two versus one is
very common so we do this kind of
training once you good at the one versus
one two versus one and then you can why
this is many depends on you if you're
good at it you can do like that there's
no problem
the moves very realistic you have to
stay with them long weapon is a big
challenge if this person get into you
very close to you you have to think
about it because you hold a longer base
if I hold it like a normal stuff I can
strap the stuff easily against track
with the back but the long way is very
difficult you have maybe hold the thing
they're trying to push to this passion
back every weapons needs a break point
break point means the energy release
Point normally on the top or in the end
sometimes you use the middle energy
point you can see the straps he always
strike with the top of his stuff that's
the energy point so the people what
they're trying to get in closer which
means trying to avoid the three point
the energy point
walk down
this is realistic in the combite but in
the movie they want to make a look cool
to have the exaggerate the moves they do
have some pressure points he used this
energy to bounce back to hit if you hit
here with the power you do get someone
knocked over your knee just knock over
give this move a thing as well
the movement is good two this is one the
one person is using stuff technique you
can turn back even my opponent in the
back you can feel behind I focus here I
know someone made me use this side you
can see in the back you can hold your
stuff in the back and then because hold
it back someone trying to strike at me
my stuff will block it I can use it to
come back to strike you have to be very
versatile and flexible in a real Combat
there's no specific rules or steps
foreign
moves if you don't want unless you're
very good you do the moves like jump
higher stream your stuff because I think
he's using the lightsaber at the end so
that's why I hold in the center use two
sides a spring point to strike that's
good hey speak his stuff as well it's
all like a fundamental stuff basic
training and it's very good
that's not real sometimes in a real
Combat you can spin one Circle
to use to stop your hands speak one
Circle to use it to strap your hand
that's okay let's see your opponent here
you do a spinning strike there you can
kick here you can be flexible but too
many times that's like choreography the
movie to make you like cool you can see
the moves it's not coordinate you can
tell straight away not calling it at all
because there's no energy come from the
strike once you good at the Kung Fu
right you just naturally do it the moves
for the staff person use is very
realistic but just the spinning part
okay it's very realistic as well but
don't spend two circles you don't do
like this it's just not cool I will stay
give us seven
oh my God
that's wonderful generally use a lot of
moves say block there's a basic move for
the spear block control and step if I'm
holding spear I look at the
opportunities I watch carefully at the
opponent if he makes a strike a sword
coming not here yet you can block and
then you do the next you react to it you
do the next move
if you're good at that you can use that
talk about the flips leave you know how
to flow with the energy is not tiring
you not get injured unless you do more
over and over over you get tired for
some people they don't know how to do it
they do one they'll be like exhausted
I love all of his moves because it's
very good it's very flow plus
you can see wusu is more like flexible
flow and also break points and fast as
well and in kung fu we see not just
physical it's the spirit as well
together come back together as one you
hold your stuff or you hold a spear
together the movement will be different
alive
that's very good very good so the
Mandarin for spear is called Chang the
real thing is Singapore that my hand is
changing that one is for traditionally
if I do like this to a circle to confuse
someone if I do like this even do faster
you probably get confused and then stay
by you you don't know I try to confuse
you and behind Straight Like That
so that's like a normal fear height but
it's a longer than the stop
by any real situation that is possible
if some people use the stop to stream by
you or spear the other thing if you use
too much power you heal your leg you can
do like that if you hit very hard I
really for this it will be pain see g3's
move is just flow very advanced
through training we do have this see
from this heart I can spin one round
swap to this side I can do a posture
like this if you really good at the Kung
Fu you can do any kind of pose you can
control the situation you can start like
this look at your opponent it can go you
look bad you feel the move pop
will require flow and smooth
coordination flexibility everything
together the food work is need to be
light you can see the differences right
you already see it so when you do the
moves such as the beginning the Smooth
Move that's the main doing at first some
Modern days actor and actress they can
learn the move spot they cannot learn
the internal part which is the feeling
the spirit inside
1-0
1 that's very important in the training
you have know how to control your power
in the sparring training even though we
punch I can use full energy but I
control to not let my training partner
to get hurt I can go this I know here to
stop I don't go past that breakpoint the
free point I say three point energy
release point they don't go bad they go
past your opponent will be more get
injured
the moves is very practical very
realistic even though they are using
stuff they are using sword technique
when they're holding stuff think about
that my arm is a star but this move this
move right this move Papa holder stop is
a sewer technique like a fundamental
move to make sure your wrist become
flexible you can use it as choke and
then to like this also combine some
stuff technique as well such as sweep
and this is shop like sword chop The
Comeback choreography very practical the
combat the camera are moving always make
me a little bit dizzy to watch let's say
eight
all right
I like this one this is like a more a
traditional style if there's a molding
style traditional style so traditional
style is a more like practical if you go
to a battlefield right the sword coming
I can just blow very straightforward
Blood come back and step a traditional
style doesn't do too much fancy moves
it's just practical
[Applause]
it's very realistic in a combat you
really need to do like that trying to
see like a you know pretty spear you can
combat your kicks come on your Flying
Kicks together right kung fu is a
holistic training if you want to master
one thing you have to holistic training
you have to do the kicks training you
have to do the stencil training you can
see the spirit they have a stencil
training their basic stances you have to
know and then there's a basic kicks you
have to know basic Flying Kicks now you
have the separate every single move to
combine other moves together to be able
to good at it it feels like you're
moving with him together you can see his
body language everything that's very
good that's very realistic and also
Advanced I really for this will be pain
my favorite one is like a Jet Li's one
The Fearless One the reading is I do the
same style ASU I enjoy the moves as a
flow and also smooth Curry geography
everything together and make it like a
real as well if you enjoy the video
please click above for another